all right listen I appreciate you taking
the time to do this before I let you go
get answer aliens your favorite book but
uh believer or non-believer you know I
was I was a biotech genetic guy by trade
and there's there's a great quote by
Douglas Adams who the famous author and
I'm gonna Massacre the quote so I'm
sorry but it's something along the lines
of you know can we appreciate the garden
for being beautiful without having to
believe that fairies live underneath and
he's of course probably talking about
atheism but you know there's so much
wonder in amazing things in our world
you know and what with in thinking about
the natural world and and look at things
that coming out of the ocean during the
tsunamis and exploration and so much
wonderment even as terrible it is like
the fact that there's these tiny viruses
that can cause such a massive disruption
to our entire planet world you know that
do do I believe that aliens possible
absolutely I think it's one of two camps
they're either super smart and leaving
us alone or they're probably just tell
and out there but like many things it
wouldn't surprise me either way i I
don't think you know my my little bitty
brain is really able to comprehend that
there's an old Asimov short story and
I'm not going to be able to remember the
name I'll send it to you we can put it
in show no it's that kind of touches on
this perfectly and I'll leave it to the
readers because I want to spoil it but
it's a great book so yeah III imagine my
bet would be there are but if I live in
LA so they probably live amongst us
already if you walk up to various parts
of LA it may be here already so you
brought up the ocean I usually ask
people would you rather go to space or
to the depths of the
Oshin which one is kind of more
intriguing to you um you know I come
from a family of aerospace guys my dad
was an old-school Martin Marietta
Lockheed you know when he passed away I
very fondly remember going through a lot
of his files that were somehow stamped
confidential that he seemed to keep at
shouldn't've my brother works on rockets
at Northrop I started out as an
aerospace engineer before I realized
that actually entailed a lot of classes
and statics and dynamics and a lot more
math than I wanted so I you know if you
were to ask the ten-year-old me I would
have said I wanted to be a astronaut and
and learned the aerospace engineering
was not the same thing as being an
astronaut by the way so for me it would
be space for sure so I give it I
probably give it a if I was a betting
man odds that it happens in our lifetime
where we get to go up there but um we'll
see I love the ocean too we live right
at the ocean here in Angeles in
Manhattan Beach so I spend a lot of time
floating around and trying to not kill
myself surfing I love it we're on where
can people go read the blog and then
also we'll find you on Twitter so my day
job is CEO and CIO of cambrie
investments which websites camera
investment camera investments calm or
Cambria funds we manage eleven ETFs
which we didn't even talk about today
which is good all quant base all sorts
of strategies stocks bonds global asset
allocation tail risk everything in
between I can find over 2,000 blog posts
and meb favor comm watch me pick fights
on Twitter I'm AB favored and of course
the podcast which you'll have to come on
and join us one of these days to as an M
favor show and by the way all of our
books are free to download because I
have a still have a running fight with
Amazon so if you go to our website you
can download all of our books and white
paper for free what yeah you got a time
real quick what's the fight with Amazon
you know you already hit like my main
funny bone which is the buyback topic
this is probably number two
Amazon look love the
and he use it every day transform the
world but the problem is they built kind
of a crappy marketplace to where for
many years many many many years people
could just upload whatever products they
want and so I had one many times where
people email me and say meb trying to
buy your IV portfolio book why is it 90
bucks and I said it's not 90 bucks what
are you talking about it's ten or two or
whatever they are and and I say send me
the link and then I'd go to the link and
it'd be kind of a wonky page where you
know the normal book has whatever
hundreds reviews this one may have three
then I look down the publisher and the
publisher with some dude's name and it
was published in like 1960 or something
and what Amazon enabled was people to
fraudulently upload more than one entry
for a book so mine would maybe have ten
or twenty so if you googled the Ivy
portfolio in that favor or bobasa
allocation the first one would be me you
know they'd get the right one but if you
maybe google faber IV or something you
would get maybe the first listing would
be the one that's ninety bucks
so it was an arbitrage where intelligent
people and wherever they maybe would
list fraudulent versions of the book now
you'd still get the book but instead of
paying ten you would pay ninety and so
that's a really terrible way to destroy
trust now Amazon didn't care because
they got paid and the seller didn't care
because they got paid but it hurts both
the author as well as the buyer so I
emailed Jeff one day Bezos and let them
know and we did a post on Twitter where
I was like by the way authors I'll send
a bottle of wine to the person who has
the most fraudulent books and someone
had like 60 I think Jim O'Shaughnessy
has been a guest I think under podcast
had like 20 and eventually they cleaned
it up and so you don't find that as much
anymore
there's also fake products on there
don't get me started and there's also
money laundering where if you steal a
credit card and go buy something that
may be listed in the far corner that's
like 500 bucks
that's a way of laundering money and so
I had a buddy who sold one day like
$20,000
worth of his books and he's a corner I
mean nobody's buying your books what's
going on it's like I don't know some I
just bought 20 grand worth but you know
you find these situations going on
anyway hopefully they've cleaned it all
up I think they'll probably be a multi
billion dollar settlement at some point
but the good news for investors is all
my books are free now so I had enough
and I just throw them online so that I
won't pick the fight anymore